there's a growing rift in Syria within
the president's inner circle Bashar
al-assad's Bashar al-assad's cousin a
business tycoon has refused to step down
as head of the largest mobile operator
in the country in a 16 minute video
posted online
I mean Makhlouf says the collapse of
Syria tell would be a catastrophic
setback for the economy he says he's
under pressure to hand over profits from
his telecommunications empire or face
arrest this is the third such video
Makhlouf has posted in recent weeks I
won't step down if I resign I would be
failing the company and the country the
height of the war I did not abandon my
country my president all my folks to do
it now well the 15 year old billionaire
is considered the wealthiest and one of
the most powerful men in Syria before
the war began in early 2011 he
controlled 60% of the economy this
allowed him to build an independent
power base apart from Syria tell his
business empire ranges from real estate
to construction and oil trading he's
been under US and EU sanctions since
2008 for what Washington calls public
corruption well Joseph deya is a swiss
syrian academic at the European
University Institute in Florence he
joins us now live from Geneva thank you
for your time how significant is this
rift between Bashar al-assad and his
cousin good evening thank you for
imitation nor the rift has been ongoing
now for nearly years it began actually
in the summer 2019 the first measures
taken against Roma mcglue and some of
his key institutions such as Syria tel
and boustan charity foundation but it
became much clearer in the past few
weeks
there is a clear offensive from the
Assad's inner circle if you want the
presidential palace represented at the
head by Bashar Assad but with also his
code is T as we say his brother ma Assad
and his wife as man I said it is a clear
offensive against Rami Makhlouf and his
economic power but not only his networks
that he was able to build
through this economic Empire which Syria
represents the ground level it's its
main economic asset it's the most
probably the largest private company in
Syria with more than six point five
thousand employees it has 11 million
subscribers
it has assets of more than 250 million
US dollars and its market share is
nearly seventy one percent so there's a
clear offensive from Assad's
presidential palace if you want against
much loose in in in a framework of
reducing economic source of rents
therefore more competition but it's also
linked to cutting any kind of patronage
networks that remember groups has in the
in the country so ending the forms of
autonomy you used to have in the country
that's why I drill down on that a little
bit more I mean is this a sort of
reordering of things for Bashar al-assad
of how he plans to rule or wants to rule
Syria going forward it's definitely a
deeper concentration of power within us
at hands and within the Assad family
directly it's not any more like prior to
the to the uprising in 2011 basically
Assad maklouf ruling together it's only
the presidential palace and this is
these are the results of various
evolutions during the war but more
especially the growing economic rule
that has been playing my heart Assad
through his fourth Brigade
arm arm division that has taken an
increasing economic role during this
past few years whether in trade and
smuggling and therefore they want to
control what was traditionally the
traditional realm of loose rule within
as a serious ruling strata economy so
it's definitely a way to concentrate
even more power in the presidential
palace this event dispensed it
represents
that's the the power side of things what
about the cash side of things I mean so
many years of war is Bashar al-asad
cash-strapped is that part of it I mean
definitely accumulating funds for the
Assad's family as a presidential palace
and the state is an important a an
important issue but I would like to
remember that this is not a campaign
against corruption whether or not in in
the objective of accumulating more funds
for the state this regime has been ruled
by a near Mafia family that owns the
state there have been new rising
businessmen that are completely I
created with the regime and - which are
representing a competition - whose rule
in the economy and he actually accused
them of being war profiteers and he
would be the nice businessman that
accumulated honestly his money prior to
the war which is obviously not the case
and also what would like to remind that
it was the the Syrian state that
provided the munition of taxes to Syria
tell in mid-2014
2015 and to also to the Ottoman
telecommunication company company in the
country MTM they had their taxes reduced
from 60% to 20% so we must be clear this
is a clash a rift among the highest
strata of the ruling family the the
presidential palace is launching an
offensive to concentrate more power this
is the key objective of Bashar Assad and
the presidential palace
more generally thank you so much for
explaining all that that's Joseph de
haar there an academic at the European
University Institute thank you